ein Hinweis bevor es losgeht in diesem
Podcast werden unter anderem
Verstümmelungen und Kannibalismus
thematisiert denjenigen denen solche
Schilderungen zu nahe gehen raten wir
vom Hören ab Tatort Deutschland
präsentiert den dunklen Januar jeden Tag
ein neuer Kriminalfall ein tägliches
Tatort Deutschland Spezial mein Name ist
Skadi und ich wünsche euch eine
spannende Krimizeit
und mein Name ist Natalie Strauß hallo
und herzlich willkommen zu unserer
heutigen Folge Tatort Deutschland
Spezial einen Monat lang präsentiert
Bild euch täglich von Montag bis Freitag
spektakuläre true crime-fälle von der
Antike bis in die Gegenwart heute
berichten wir von abscheulichen Taten
die allen jahrhundert zurücklegen und
bis heute nichts von ihrem Schrecken
verloren haben wieder an meiner Seite
Mirko Kasimir Sprechern Moderator hallo
Mirko ich glaube nach der heutigen Folge
sollten wir definitiv ein äußerst
starken Kaffee trinken oder oder ja
besser sogar ein Schnaps doppelten ein
Natalie ja das glaube ich auch ich grüße
dich hallo neben all dem Grauen über das
wir täglich sprechen freue ich mich aber
immer wieder aufs Neue dich vor mir zu
haben du mich erleichtert das auch total
hier in dein Gesicht zu schauen und mich
da so ein bisschen abzulenken von diesen
grausamen Taten über die wir gleich
sprechen werden bei dem Fall den wir
euch heute erzählen schüttet es mich so
richtig über 20 Jahre lang tötete der
Kannibale von Münsterberg mindestens ja
wohl bemerkt mindestens 30 Menschen bis
er schließlich überführt werden konnte
und Kannibale verrät es ja schon es
sollte nicht beim Töten allein bleiben
Mirko bevor wir von den schrecklichen
Taten berichten lass uns doch den
Menschen hinter dem Monster ein bisschen
besser kennenlernen wer war denn dieser
kahl denke
Vater denke wir später genannt werden
sollte wurde im Februar 1860 in einem
kleinen Dorf im damaligen Schlesien in
dem heutigen Polen geboren
er war das dritte Kind einer
Bauernfamilie von klein auf war Karl
anders als andere er war ein
verschlossenes Kind das erst im Alter
von sechs Jahren zu sprechen begann oder
besser gesagt Laute von sich zu geben in
der Schule wurde Karl von seinen Lehrern
als mürrisch trotzig oder sogar als
Idiot bezeichnet je älter der Junge
wurde desto mehr Zucker sich zurück und
kapselte sich ab während er in der
Kindheit mit einem seiner Brüder einen
freundschaftliches Verhältnis zu haben
schien verlor sich dieses Band mit der
Pubertät der Bruder beschwerte sich das
Karl sich einfach an nichts beteilige
und mit ihm nichts anzufangen sein
andere sollen ihn im Nachhinein als
empfindungslos beschrieben haben und als
einen Menschen der weder Ekel noch Angst
empfand
Familie denke Betrieb damals eine
Gastwirtschaft in der Karl nach seiner
Schulausbildung arbeitete an privaten
Festen Tanzveranstaltungen oder einem
feierabendbiername jedoch nie Teil
nächtelang soll er allein durch die
umliegenden Wälder gestreift sein was
bedeutet erlebte oder machte kam nie zu
Tage nach Beendigung seiner Schulzeit
lief Karl ohne ein Wort zu sagen von zu
Hause fort und tauchte erst knapp ein
Jahr später wieder auf auch hier ohne
ein Wort Entschuldigung oder irgendeinen
Hinweis wo er sich aufgehalten hatte na
das lässt sich jetzt erstmal nicht auf
einen Mörder schließen aber auf jeden
Fall auf eine ganz traurige Kindheit und
es ist schon verhaltensauffällig ja
ersten verschobener Typ der hat sogar
als Jugendlicher noch ins Bett gemacht
ja also das deutet auch darauf hin dass
er schwierige Probleme hat er hat auf
jeden Fall eine Entwicklungsverzögerung
und hat natürlich dementsprechend auch
keinerlei Hilfe bekommen ich meine wir
sprechen hier über 1860 da war das
bewusst für die menschliche Psyche noch
eine ganz andere und da konnte man noch
gar nicht für seine
ja für seine Belange die richtige
Betreuung bekommen ja und statt Hilfe
wurde als Idiot abgestempelt das macht
natürlich auch was mit einem ja aber wie
ging es dann weiter das Morden begann ja
erst viel später also wann wurde aus
diesem
sonderbaren Jungen aus oberkunstendorf
der Kannibale von Münsterberg
ja das dauerte tatsächlich nur knapp 20
Jahre zumindest bis zum ersten Mal der
ihm nachgewiesen werden konnte
nach dem Tod seiner Eltern sollte denke
weiter in der Gastwirtschaft aushelfen
er zog allerdings still und heimlich von
einem Tag auf den anderen Weg und lebte
fortan im benachbarten Münsterberg hier
kaufte ein Grundstück welches er zu
einem viel zu hohen Preis erwarten
daraufhin zweifelten seine Geschwister
in seiner Zurechnungsfähigkeit und
stellten einen entmündigungsantrag
dieser wurde abgewiesen unter anderem
mit der Begründung eines Arztes dass es
gefährlich werden können Menschen wie
denke so etwas anzutun denn er könne
einen solchen Wutanfall bekommen dass
man seines Lebens auf der Straße nicht
mehr sicher sei
nach diesem Vorfall brach der Kontakt zu
den Geschwistern ab nur ein einziges Mal
gab es noch ein Wiedersehen als er bei
seinem Bruder zum Essen eingeladen war
dort soll er etwa zwei Pfund Fleisch
gegessen haben sein Bruder und andere
beschrieben ihn als Vielfraß aber denke
kaufte nicht nur ein Grundstück er
mietete sich auch in Münsterberg eine
Wohnung in einem drei Parteienhaus von
lebt ein Lehrer mit seiner Familie und
hinten im ersten Stock ein Arbeiter
Ehepaar und darunter am Erdgeschoss Karl
Denker die Wohnung bestand lediglich aus
einem Zimmer von etwa vier mal vier
Metern hier schlief aus und arbeitete er
und wie erst viel später klar wurde hier
ermordete zerteilte und aß er 30
Menschen
boah da dreht sich mir der Magen um na
der wird mir jetzt schon ganz an dass
ich meine sogar ein Arzt hat bestätigt
dass es nicht auszuschließen sei das
denke gefährlich werden könnte und in
dem Haus hat er ja auch nicht allein
gelebt also irgendwer muss das doch
mitbekommen du kannst ja nicht einfach
so unbemerkt 30 Leute zerteilen naja
darauf komme ich später noch zurück ich
sag mal nur so viel manchmal ist das
Offensichtliche zu offensichtlich um es
zu glauben außerdem war Karl in seiner
neuen Nachbarschaft durchaus Berlin
liebt auch wenn er in seinem Heimatdorf
als mürrische Idiot bekannt war in
Münsterberg wurde er zwar als ruhig und
sonderlich beschrieben aber auch als
gutmütiger Mann der Landstreicher und
Handwerksburschen mit Essen versorgte
dieses Verhalten brachte ihm den
Spitznamen Vater oder auch Papa denke
ein er brachte keine Mädchen mit nach
Hause und im Alkohol konnte er allem
Anschein nach auch nichts abgewinnen
sein Geld verdiente er unter anderem mit
selbst geflochtenen kaum ein ruhiger
etwas sonderbare aber angenehmer Nachbar
später stellte sich allerdings heraus
dass einige Weidenzweige der von denke
hergestellten Körbe mit Menschenhaut
zusammen geflochten wurden das ist
richtig dunkel also er fällt nicht auf
ist still aber wirkt auch nicht
aggressiv oder jähzornig ist sogar
freundlich und hilfsbereit
einige beschreiben ihm im Nachhinein als
schizophren der verschlossene
entwicklungsverzögerte bettnässende
junge und der kaltblütige Mörder eine
tatsächliche psychische Erkrankung wurde
ihm aber nie nachgewiesen ich meine es
liegt ja auch immerhin knapp 100 Jahre
zurück ich muss ehrlich sagen ich komme
immer noch nicht drauf klar dass er in
dieser kleinen ein Zimmer putze getötet
hat und keiner hat's bemerkt ja Menschen
zerteilen das klingt meiner Meinung nach
anders als ein paar weitere Körper zu
flechten das eine ist laut du brauchst
daher Segen Messer weiß ich nicht alles
und ein Kopf Flechten das bekommt er
kein Mensch mit das muss doch jemand
gehört haben ja dann wird es das wohl
Zeit dass wir uns mit der düsteren Seite
von Karl denke beschäftigen wir gehen
zurück an den Tag an dem sein 31
Opfer entkam und denke es taten
aufgedeckt wurden am 21 Dezember 1924
kam der Wanderarbeiter Vinzenz Olivier
zu denken und bat ihn um etwas zu essen
dieser reichte ihm zunächst gepökeltes
Fleisch und bat ihn anschließend darum
ihm für 20 Pfennig Entlohnung einem
Brief zu verfassen die Masche von Karl
denke er sei Analphabet und brauche
Hilfe beim Verfassung von Texten hat er
wohl bei all seinen Opfern angewendet in
Wirklichkeit konnte den sowohl schreiben
als auch rechnen man fand später eine
genaue Liste seiner Opfer in die er auch
deren Gewichte eingetragen hatte Olivier
setzte sich jedenfalls an den Tisch und
bekam die folgenden Worte diktiert Adolf
du dicker weinst verwundert drehte sich
der Bursche zu Karl denke um und konnte
gerade noch rechtzeitig der herabsausen
den Spitzhacke ausweichen die denke auf
ihn niederschmetterte
die Hacke verfehlte seinen Schädel um
Millimeter und hinterließ eine 8 cm
lange Platzwunde an der Schläfe
geistesgegenwärtig bekannt der junge
Mann die Spitzhacke zu fassen und
schaffte es sie dem 64-Jährigen denke
abzunehmen olivieris die Wohnungstür auf
und schrie um Hilfe diese Rufe hörten
einige Hausbewohner und kamen ihn zu
Hilfe nur mit Mühe konnten sie den
Burschen aus den Händen denkes befreien
dieser saß mit Zitat gerötetem
verzerrten Gesicht und stieren Blick da
knirschte mit den Zähnen und wurde ab
und zu von Zuckungen die über den ganzen
Körper liefen geschüttelt bei der
Polizei wollte zunächst niemand Vinzenz
Olivier Glauben schließlich genoss Vater
denke einen guten Ruf in der Stadt
manche Quellen berichten sogar das
Olivier zunächst wegen des Verdachts auf
Bettelei und Landstreicherei angeklagt
wurde der Richter ihm aber
schlussendlich doch glaubte und denke
verhaften ließ
ich finde das beweist wieder einmal wie
der ein vermeintlich guter Ruf helfen
kann ich meine das muss man sich mal
vorstellen da steht ein Mann Blut
überströmt mit der Spitzhacke in denkes
Wohnung ja wird das so aufgefunden und
trotzdem glaubt man Oliver erstmal nicht
das ist doch das ist doch verrückt wie
viel muss passieren damit Menschen
helfen Eingreifen damit sie hinschauen
und dir Glauben schenken ja aber dann
stand eine Hausdurchsuchung bei Karl
denke an also sollte dann wirklich alles
ans Licht kommen aber der Mörder selbst
sollte nie Rechenschaft dafür ablegen
genau denn denke wusste natürlich was
die Polizei in seiner Wohnung finden
würde und beschloss sich deshalb nicht
einem Richter und seinen Taten zu
stellen
Karl denke beging noch in der ersten
Nacht in seiner Zelle Selbstmord dafür
nahm ein Stofftaschentuch formte daraus
eine Schlinge und befestigte es mit
Riemen an Ringen die für eine
festkettung vorgesehen waren so erhängt
er sich in liegender Stellung und wählte
selbst die Bestrafung für seine Morde
ohne das Wissen das Karl denke bereits
tot war durchsuchte die Polizei seine
Wohnung und was sie dort fanden
überstieg jegliche Erwartung im Zimmer
standen mehrere Fässer vollgepökeltem
Fleisch in anderen Kübeln fand man rohes
Fleisch welches sich als die Brust und
des Gesäß eines Mannes sind Punkte in
verschiedenen Töpfen Schwamm eine
gallertartige Fettmasse
in zwei Blechbüchsen wurden 420 Zähne
aufbewahrt schnell wurde ein Mediziner
herbeigerufen der feststellte dass es
sich bei den Funden ausnahmslos um
Menschenfleisch handelte insgesamt 480
Körperteile ausgekochte Knochen Rippen
und Schädel wurden entdeckt auf dem
Tisch standen Dosen mit gekochten
Fleisch in einer Sahnesoße von der die
Hälfte wohl unmittelbar vorher von denke
verschweißt wurde aber das war noch
nicht alles man Fahrt außerdem drei Paar
Hosenträger etwa 6 cm breit und 70 cm
lang die denke aus Menschen gefertigt
hatte an einem Paar erkannte man noch
die Brustwarzen alle Träger zeigten
Spuren des Gebrauchs Karl denke trug
sogar ein paar menschliche Hosenträger
als er verhaftet wurde dazu fanden sich
Riemen aus Menschen Haut die denke zur
Fertigung von Karben Schuhbändern oder
sonstigen Männchen verwendete auch im
lumpen und Wäschestücke zusammenzubinden
an vielen Teilen waren noch
Menschenhaare zu finden neben all diesen
grausigen Funden hatte der Kannibale
denke auch Ausweispapiere seine Opfer
aufbewahrt und es tauchte die Liste auf
in der er die Namen von 30 Opfern
aufgeführt hatte bei allen 20 mindestens
der Vorname und das Datum ihres
todestages angefangen mit einer Ida
launa am 21 februar 1903 bis zu einem
noch nicht zu Ende ausgeführten Kästchen
das wohl für Vincents Olivier vorgesehen
war bei vielen Opfern statt außerdem
noch Geburtsdatum Wohnort und Beruf der
Person in der Regel außerdem noch das
Gewicht vor und nach der sagen wir so
wie es ist Ausschlachtung einen weiteren
Beweis zu den vermissten Personen
lieferten diverse Kleidungsstücke die
später von den Angehörigen der Opfer
identifiziert werden konnten wahnsinn
das ist so grauenhaft und auch super
ekelerregend ich denke mir immerhin hat
denke die Opfer wohl nicht extra gequält
die Körperteile die Wiesen nämlich
keinerlei Merkmale auf dass ihnen die
Wunden oder Zerteilung lebendig angetan
worden das ist aber macht das Ganze
nicht weniger furchtbar wahrscheinlich
war es bei den meisten wie bei Olivier
sie wurden gebeten sich hinzusetzen
einen Brief zu schreiben und dann
rücklings erschlagen oder erwürgt die
Mord schlachtwerkzeuge hat man
anschließend auch gefunden es handelt
sich hierbei um dreieckste eine große
Holzsäge eine Baumsäge eine Spitzhacke
und drei Messer
für eine Person hatte die Aufklärung
etwas bitteres aber auch was Gutes das
zweite Opfer denkt es war eine Frau mit
dem Namen Emma
1909 wurde in Münsterberg die Leiche der
Frau gefunden und für diese Tat wanderte
damals der Fleischer Eduard Trautmann
ins Gefängnis er hatte die Haft
abgesessen und wurde wegen guter Führung
nach zwölf Jahren entlassen nach dem
Fund von denkes Liste wurde
trautmannsfall neu aufgenommen und er im
Nachhinein für unschuldig erklärt
21 Jahre lang mordete zerstückelte und
eiskalt denke insgesamt 30 Menschen ob
er schon vorher gemordet hat das kann
keiner so wirklich sagen es wird
angenommen dass er die Opfer selbst
verspeiste oder Landstreichern
Handwerksburschen wie Olivier zu essen
gab die Nachbarn haben angegeben dass
sie es durchaus sonderbar fanden wie
viel Fleisch denke immer zu Hause hatte
und das in einer Zeit in der Fleisch
etwas Kostbares und sehr seltenes war
aber sie nahmen einfach an dass er
schwarz Hunde schlachtete und haben sich
nicht weiter dafür interessiert auch
wenn ihnen eigentlich hätte auffallen
können wie viele Hunde das gewesen sein
müssten es ist fast schon
ignorant und unglaublich wie alle
einfach die Augen verschlossen haben
oder nicht Mirko naja natürlich es ist
nicht so dass über die Jahre nie was
aufgefallen wäre im Nachhinein gaben
nämlich Nachbarn an das denke häufig
einmal mit Blut oder blutigem Wasser im
Hof ausgeschüttet habe eine Nachbarin
beschwerte sich auch über den
penetranten Gestank der aus denkes
Wohnung kam man hörte Nächte lang sägen
und hämmern aus den geschwungen hier
nahm man an denke würde Schlüssel
herstellen die er danach verkaufte Papa
denke Boot außerdem immer wieder alte
Kleider und Schuhe an oder verbrannte
welche in seinem Garten wenn Knochen
gefunden wurden hebt man die für
Tierknochen das kann nachts mehrmals mit
Paketen die Wohnung verließ schien auch
niemanden zu stören er ging sogar ganz
ungestört mit offenen Töpfen mit dem
Fleisch über den Hof und niemand machte
sich was dabei aber was unglaublich ist
ist das Vinzenz Olivier nicht der erste
war der entkam es gab wohl über die
Jahre immer wieder Menschen die aus
denke es Wohnungen flohen aber keiner
erstattete jemals Anzeige für die
Nachbarn war er der ruhige Sonderling
mit einem Herz für Landstreicher und
Wanderarbeiter insgesamt 30 Menschen
fielen diesem scheinbar hilfsbereiten
Mann zum Opfer darunter vier Frauen wenn
es eine Erklärung für dieses barbarische
Verhalten gab so nahm Papa denke sie mit
den sein Grab der Gerichtsmediziner
friedrich petruski sagte nach der
Untersuchung von Karls Leiche Zitat hier
der duldsame friedfertige gutmütige alte
Sonderling dort die mordgierige Bestie
die Menschen meuchelte fraß und aus
ihrer Haut riemenschnitt
das ist denke seine Krankheit kann man
Perversion oder vornehmer paraffinin
nennen doch deswegen weiß noch immer
kein Mensch woher der ewige Zwang zum
Menschen fressen stammte Zitat Ende
boah das ist so ein harter Brocken was
ich mich aber von Anfang bis Ende Frage
was daran ist krank und was hat das
Umfeld aus Karl denke gemacht ich meine
du kommst ja nicht einfach als
schlechter Mensch auf die Welt oder da
muss schon irgendwas schief gelaufen
sein oder irgendwie musst du anders
gepolt sein wenn du dann aber auch noch
nicht genug Liebe bekommst gemobbt wirst
als Kind etc und einfach immer wie ein
Alien als als anders betrachtet wirst
und auch so behandelt wirst das macht
was mit dir später als Erwachsener da
trifft er dann auf die Ignoranz der
Nachbarschaft bei den Erwachsenen das
macht mich wütend das macht mich stutzig
gleichzeitig zeigt es aber auch wieder
dass Menschen am liebsten immer gar
nichts damit zu tun haben wollen mit den
Problemen anderer und sich gerne auch
mal wegducken das hat natürlich sein
Verhalten gefördert Natalie da bin ich
ganz bei dir die Situation in seiner
Kindheit mit Sicherheit eine Rolle
gespielt aber ich weigere mich irgendwie
das als einziger Erklärung dafür zu
sehen weil er ist nicht der einzige
einstehen ist dem es in seiner Kindheit
schlecht gegangen ist jetzt nicht der
einzige der Leid erfahren hat der
vielleicht schlecht behandelt wurde und
nicht jeder dem sowas dem so etwas
widerfahren ist wird zum Schluss zum
Serienmörder ja also das werden
sicherlich viele
Faktoren eine Rolle gespielt haben was
mich bewegt dabei beziehungsweise was
mir durch den Kopf geht ist die Frage
der Fall liegt der ungefähr 100 Jahre
zurück würde so etwas denn heute
eigentlich genauso noch passieren das
ist unbemerkt von der Öffentlichkeit
solche Fälle solche Mordserien geben
würde ja und ich glaube die Antwort ist
eigentlich ganz klar ja vielleicht unter
anderem Vorzeichen und unter anderem
Umständen und vielleicht wird es auch
eher aufgedeckt werden aber mir fällt
natürlich sofort der Fall jeffreyama ein
ja es gibt die bekannte Serie auf
Netflix die diesen Fall ja noch mal
darstellt mir war das auch schon vorher
bekannt wie auch vielen anderen sicher
und auch er hat es ja geschafft und
dieser Fall liegt das 30 Jahre zurück
viele Menschen zu töten hat auch von dem
Fleisch gegessen und auch da gibt es
sicherlich parallelen die sich zwischen
diesen beiden Fällen abspielen ich denke
grundsätzlich sind solche Fälle auch
heute nicht auszuschließen aber es wäre
wohl heutzutage viel schwieriger für
einen potenziellen Täter seine Taten zu
verheimlichen denn die Aufmerksamkeit
ist heutzutage viel höher und das kommt
sicherlich auch wegen der sehr hohen und
sehr starken medialen Präsenz solcher
Themen die er selbst wenn sie schon
Jahre oder Jahrzehnte vergangen sind
durch Dokumentation durch True Crime
Podcasts immer wieder
hervorgehoben werden und neu diskutiert
werden ich glaube wir können festhalten
dass wir nicht genau erklären können wie
es zu diesen grauenvollen Tagen gekommen
ist wie Karl denke zu dieser Person
geworden ist aber fest steht dass in der
heutigen Zeit in Deutschland glaube ich
so ohne weiteres keine Person unbemerkt
verschwinden könnte und ein Mann der was
ich zu Hause schlachtet oder literweise
Blut im Kuli auf dem Hof entsorgen würde
und dabei kein Metzger oder Jäger ist
der hätte wohl glaube ich ziemlich
schnell Nachbarn und Polizei auf dem
Hals da bin ich wirklich schon sehr
dankbar dass wir in der heutigen Zeit
leben und nicht vor 100 Jahren aber aber
ganz ausschließen lassen sich solche
Fälle eben nicht das ist einfach so kalt
Denker ein Fall der uns nicht loslässt
obwohl er schon Jahrzehnte zurückliegt
grausige Taten wären Beschreibung damals
wie heute nur schwer zu ertragen sind
wir danken euch fürs zuhören und hoffen
dass ihr bei der nächsten Folge auch
wieder dabei sein werdet bei Tatort
Deutschland Spezial euer Mirko und eure
Natalie
den Fall denke haben wir erzählt mit dem
Text der vergessene Kannibale vaterdenke
des forensikers mark Benecke sowie mit
historischen Zitaten aus der deutschen
zeitschrift für die gesamte gerichtliche
Medizin Redaktion Antonia Haier und
Stefan Netzeband
Produktion Serverdienst